[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 17 mars édition spéciale
sur tv soixante dix huit pour faire le
point sur la situation et du coronavirus
dans les yvelines
j'ai décidé de renforcer encore les
mesures pour réduire nos déplacements et
nos contacts au strict nécessaire dès
demain midi et pour quinze jours au
moins nos déplacements seront très
fortement réduit cela signifie que les
regroupements extérieur les réunions
familiales ou amicales ne seront plus
permises se promet retrouver ses amis
dans le parc dans la rue ne sera plus
possible
il s'agit de limiter au maximum ses
contacts au delà du fond la france est
en guerre les mots forts utilisés par le
président de la république emmanuel
macron dans son allocution aux français
le chef d'état a annoncé le confinement
total du pays pour 15 jours minimum
ultime étape du plan de lutte contre la
propagation du colis de 19 depuis midi
les sorties sont limités au strict
minimum et aux besoins essentiels plus
de regroupement extérieure et une
attestation à présenter désormais aux
forces de l'ordre pour justifier votre
déplacement
une première réaction à vous proposer
suite à ces annonces celle de la députée
aurore bergé pour parole de la
république en marche sont des mesures
qui sont absolument nécessaires parce
que notre sujet c'est évidemment la
santé publique est depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire on a une chose très
simple on suivrait l'avis des
scientifiques et les scientifiques nous
ont dit qu'il fallait absolument on
puisse s'en passer par une période de
confinement pour éviter la propagation
je sais à quel point ça peut être
inconfortables quand on est loin de ses
proches prendre ses parents au loin de
ses grands parents etc on peut
s'inquiéter et que l'on n'a pas la
possibilité de sortir comme on le
souhaiterait mais c'est une nécessité
absolue pour nous mêmes et pour les
autres pour qu'on puisse se protéger
même position pour martha 2,6 drague
sénatrice des yvelines ces dispositions
de confinement aurait pu même être prise
plus tôt la parlementaire qui appelle
également au calme écoutez je crois que
c'est une mesure tout à fait raisonnable
compte tenu du contexte
vraisemblablement pesé réfléchi mûrement
donc de mon point de vue je pense que
c'était la bonne mesure à prendre dans
l'est dans les circonstances actuelles
après on peut s'interroger pourquoi
maintenant pourquoi pas plutôt etc mais
je pense que c'est la bonne mesure au
moment où elle a été annoncée oui moi je
crois que nous avons la chance d'être
dans un pays quand même qui globalement
bien tenues bien organisé je crois qu'il
faut qu'on garde notre sang froid qu'on
soit tous à la fois raisonnable mais
aussi vraiment unis aujourd'hui nous
sommes tous sur le même bateau et
aujourd'hui nous sommes en confinement
ne sommes pas en restriction nouvelle
accueillie également assez bien par les
maires qui organise la suite pour leur
commune notamment à maurepas l'interview
du maire par mélanie potier les
dispositions que le président du lille
que nous demande de prendre sont
évidemment légitime et on doit les
appliquer étant donnée la prolifération
du virus
il faut prendre vraiment toutes les
mesures et à maurepas évidemment nous
les avons prises également à la suite de
l'intervention du président de la
république voire même avant la totalité
des services municipaux sont fermés nous
autorisons l'école de la balme automne
et la crèche de au boulot en urgence
pour les personnels ou les
professionnels médecins pompiers voilà
toutes les professions où la garde
d'enfants est nécessaire avec une
livraison vraiment d'europe a minima au
même titre que les quelques agents
municipaux qui reste en mairie sinon la
plupart des agents communaux sont en
télétravail évidemment au maximum pour
éviter qu'ils soient en contact et les
services qui s'organise également au
niveau départemental les yvelines par la
voix de son président pierre bédier
c'est de prendre les mesures les plus à
même de contrarier l'avancée de la
pandémie sans pour autant altérer
les services aux publics indispensables
comme la protection maternelle et
infantile et l'aide sociale à l'enfance
elle les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
qui ont mis en place un numéro vert pour
les professionnels des services dead et
d'accompagnement à domicile et des
mesures aussi à saint quentin en
yvelines qui indique que la collecte des
déchets ménagers va se poursuivre
normalement
elle est cette déchetterie sont elles
fermées côté transports les bus
circuleront le plus normalement possible
sur le territoire sauf pour les réseaux
de substitution de la ligne u qui est à
l'arrêt l agglomération ont mobilisé
également sur le réseau d'eau potable
toute anomalie est à signaler sur le
portail app est ce ce mardi 17 mars 2020
fera donc date dans l'histoire en france
depuis midi le confinement a débuté dans
le pays pour lutter contre la
propagation du vide 19 on retrouve
nicolas landry dans les rues de saint
quentin en yvelines pour nous décrire
l'atmosphère qui règne dans
l'agglomération écoutez grégory les
saint quentinois semble respecté les
consignes de confinement donné par le
président de la république ici sur
l'artère principale de l'agglomération
avenue du centre les rues sont quasiment
déserte tout à l'heure nous avons
constaté que deux policiers ont
interpellé deux jeunes mais pour faire
de la prévention ils les ont
raccompagnés chez eux
enfin les véhicules du réseau stibus
circulent mais quasiment vide
pour rappel un concrètement les français
ont l'obligation de rester chez eux
depuis ce midi
cependant plusieurs déplacements reste
possible mais il faudra vous munir de
l'autorisation de déplacement
dérogatoire pour le justifier avec
plusieurs motifs par exemple pour se
rendre sur des visites médicales pour
aller au travail lorsque le télétravail
n'est pas possible et que votre
entreprise poursuit son activité ou
encore pour faire ses courses
l'exemple le plus flagrant c'est que ce
matin devant l'enseigne de grande
distribution du centre commercial espace
saint quentin
il y avait beaucoup de monde pour faire
la queue pour aller faire leurs courses
maintenant il y a quasiment personne
mais pour vous rassurer le directeur de
ce magasin nous a confié qu'il n'y
aurait pas de pénurie
nicolas nourris avec nicolas
kirillovitch pour
les moyens techniques et depuis les
annonces des manuels macron des scènes
assez similaires ont pu se voir dans les
yvelines comme sur ces images à montigny
le bretonneux et à poissy des personnes
faisant la queue pendant de nombreuses
minutes pour pouvoir accéder aux
commerces qui peuvent rester ouverts
pendant cette période elle la plupart du
temps dans le plus grand calme mais
certains supermarchés ont dû fermer
leurs portes en raison de mouvements de
panique c'est ce que dénonce sur twitter
la député des yvelines
aurore bergé que l'on a entendu tout à
l'heure est des scènes qui se sont
déroulés en vallée de chevreuse ou des
vigiles ont été frappés à trappes c'est
une épicerie qui a été dévalisé dans la
nuit avenue hector berlioz est la
supérette était fermé depuis plusieurs
mois de nombreux services et commerces
ont donc baissé le rideau les maires les
mairies ne reçoivent plus de public
d'autres lieux cependant restent ouverts
en cette période de confinement ont fait
le point avec nicolas kirillovitch une
agglomération ralenti excepté dans
certains commerces comme dans le reste
de la france
l'ensemble des supermarchés hypermarchés
commerce de détail reste ouvert à saint
quentin en yvelines pour y faire ses
courses il vous faudra tout de même vous
armer de patience une solution peut être
vous rendre dans les boucheries
fromageries et autres commerces de
détail ou encore à la ferme de grignon
la boutique gourmande restent ouvertes à
la vente directe rester ouverts aussi
dans l'agglomération les pharmacies les
garages stations service les magasins
spécialisés dans l'informatique tabac
hôtels mais aussi plus étonnant
peut-être les papeteries blanchisserie
et laveries du côté des services de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines le réseau stibus est maintenue
bien que réduit sur les lignes
desservant les établissements scolaires
même chose pour les trains depuis les
gares de l'agglomération avec une
réduction pour l'instant légère du
trafic
tous les autres équipements publics
piscine médiathèque et lieux
touristiques sont quant à eux fermés
depuis vendredi l'île de loisirs a dû
elle aussi se résoudre à fermer son
accès aux piétons aujourd'hui tout comme
les parcs et espaces verts des communes
enfin les services d'accueil des mairies
de l'agglomération sont pour leur grande
majorité totalement
fermé au public des permanences
téléphoniques et des contacts par mail
sont encore possibles pour plus de
précision elle l'idéal est de consulter
les sites internet des communes les
collectes de sang aussi sont autorisés
par l'état pendant le confinement les
citoyens sont autorisés à se déplacer
pour aller donner leur sang sur les
sites de collecte sous réserve qu'il
remplisse l'attestation officiel ou une
déclaration sur l'honneur indiquant
qu'ils vont donner leur sang
l'établissement français du sang est
clair et les dons ne peuvent être
interrompus les réserves actuelles sont
de moins de quinze jours pour les
globules rouges - 2 3 jours pour les
plaquettes est l'une des conséquences de
ces annonces présidentielles et dont on
a parlé hier emmanuel macron c'est le
report du second tour des élections
municipales qui était prévu initialement
dimanche prochain pas de date officielle
encore elle même si le mois de juin a
été évoquée à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
cette commune qui n'ont pas réussi à
désigner leurs maires lors du premier
tour sont concernés le reportage de
mélanie poker
c'est un geste que les yvelinois comme
tous les français ne seront pas amenés à
faire avant les prochaines semaines
glisser un bulletin dans une urne ne se
fera finalement pas ce dimanche 22 mars
le parlement doit voter dans les heures
qui viennent en projet de loi qui va à
la fois permettre en effet le report du
second tour des élections c'est le
premier tour il est considéré comme
acquis donc on va prendre des
dispositions pour le report des
dispositions pour les conseils aussi
communautaire d'agglomération pour que
ça puisse continuer à fonctionner aussi
normalement possible et que les services
publics est bien évidemment une
continuité deuxième tour annulé ce sont
sept communes saint-quentinoise qui sont
concernés villepreux plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois trappe voisin
bretonneau la verrière ou encore
guyancourt on l'attendait déjà pendant
la journée d'hier bien évidemment donc
on a on n'a pas vraiment été surpris
hier soir
maintenant je pense que cette décision
est parfaitement sage et que voilà on
pourra se consacrer totalement à la
lutte contre le virus durant les
semaines et peut-être les mois à venir
cinq communes ont en revanche je suis un
maire élu au premier tour le dimanche 15
mars
elles doivent organiser un tout premier
conseil municipal à huis clos comme à
magny les hameaux ont donc
l'installation du nouveau conseil
municipal ont ce samedi à l'hôtel de
ville à huis clos puisque à priori c'est
la consigne qui devrait arriver mais on
se prépare dès maintenant et on essaye
de travailler pas de côté sur une
retransmission internet et ses conseils
d'installation doivent se tenir d'ici ce
dimanche 22 mars
pour refermer cette édition un point sur
la situation du coronavirus en
ile-de-france les derniers chiffres
publiés hier lundi par santé publique
france font état de 1762 cas de covin 19
recensés dans la région soit 553 et
nouveaux cas en 24 heures et pour
information nous ne pourrons plus vous
communiquer des statistiques yvelinoise
le pays étant au stade 3 de la pandémie
c'est désormais santé publique france
qui publiera des données régionales
voilà pour cette édition spéciale qui
touche à sa fin merci pour votre
fidélité tv 78 qui vous tiendra bien sûr
informés quotidiennement pendant cette
période elle n'hésite pas d'ailleurs à
nous partager à partager vos expériences
pendant ce confinement
une belle soirée sûreté des 78
[Musique]